elon musk is going to trial over twitter  and fast really fast twitter wanted to  go to trial in september as in just a  few days away but the chancellor aka the  judge sided with twitter and set the  trial for october as in also not very  far away elon musk wanted to set the  trial for february 2023 which was very  close to the expiration of the financing  obligations and that might have been a  bid to blow up the whole deal if you  don't have financing maybe you can't go  forward with it and musk wanted extra  time for extensive discovery related to  his too many bots on twitter theory but  that's not really relevant to whether  this particular deal needs to close so  this is generally bad news for elon musk  and good news for twitter this is fast  and as i've said before don't mess  around with the delaware chancery courts  or you might find out just like elon  musk did